[Music]
come on
it's like we're always treading water we
keep trying to hold everything together
like those we're gonna go crazy we knew
what we were getting into the adopted
beth rough morning huh
no just the world falling apart in that
case I'll see you later today okay
you should get well my mom has we
haven't had a break and sweet it from a
security standpoint it's the best in the
business
there are cameras in every room the
whole house is wired with microphone
enabled speakers with the icing on the
cake is the home automation it's like
having a virtual maid Butler and
personal assistant all rolled into one
nice to feel like things are more
manageable again how do you feel about
coming back Rachael's ours
once we get into our groove maybe we
won't need her the way
[Music]
what are you doing I'm taking her with
me
gopher Dan I guess someone was able
breaking why us never gave up looking
and looking for four years I'd never
give her up
Beth is your daughter I'm her mother too
and you know what I will do to protect
that
you